so you started in Chicago yeah did you
ever play the Schomburg improv at all
ever
um I I've never no I actually never
played that I never played Zanies either
wow but I did play Zanies like as a
showcase like being on the Showcase or
whatever but Bert who used to book it he
um
he got mad at my agent for something
that I didn't age I don't even work with
anymore and he was like well then your
client Mateo's never working here again
so I never worked Zanies but I'm doing
the Chicago theater in a couple weeks
yeah sold out yeah sold out I know it's
unbelievable oh unbelievable and my
whole family's coming I have like 34
first cousins and they're all gonna be
there and they're meeting my husband
they've not met him yet so he's gonna be
completely attacked all at once
definitely but they haven't met your
husband yet no we just got married only
my mom and dad have met him because we
did a city hall wedding which is like
getting married at oh well you guys are
so hot he's so hot oh my God this is so
too hot well we're dressed like gay club
Owners in 1978 like we've just done
cocaine but um because they're so cool I
know I love him so much there he is
Rodrigo what is you Mexican from Mexico
you're Mexican yeah it's working yeah
I look like a deli worker but you know
yeah yeah is that a one piece thread no
it does look like a one piece but yeah
two piece but whoa It's yeah well how
did you guys meet we met on Instagram oh
DM me I'm desperate I I mean look at him
of course I was the first one gonna
message him he he was doing these videos
like you know these like almost soft
core porn videos now people do like get
ready with me in the morning when
they're in their underwear you know
anyway so I was just going through my
explore page I think I was on a plane
and uh I saw him and I was like I was
like he's so hot and so then I followed
him then he followed me back and then I
was like Hey and he was like Hey and we
started chatting and then it just didn't
stop did he live in New York uh no he
lived in Mexico so I was we were going
back and forth from Mexico and New York
such a fun ldr I know it was so cute I'm
like well so he lived in Mexico you
lived in New York yeah let's talk to me
about the first time you met him uh he
came in April to New York for the first
time so we first met it did you did you
pick him up at the airport I did oh I
went all the way to JF [__] case she
has no concept of how annoying that is
and um but yeah he came out and uh I
just I we I've said and it's so gross
because I hate being sentimental but I
when I met him the first thing I thought
was oh he's gonna be in my life a very
long time and we fell in love
immediately I know we could we connect
very well and we're all we're interested
in I like details I like details wait
how long had you guys been talking
before meeting we started talking in
February so February March and then
April and he was like okay we're
FaceTiming each other good morning good
night like we need to meet she's like
yeah come to New York and he was like
all right I'm gonna get a ticket 100
good morning good night is is you guys
are on yeah did you help buy the ticket
or did you buy no he got it that's
that's great I love that why is that so
important to you he does like he's got
like modeling jobs and Commercial work
and stuff in in Mexico uh
why is that important to me yeah
well I'm just saying if I met somebody
right and they were like I want to come
out and I'm like okay you have to buy
the ticket
to me yeah it would make me feel a
little weird that's all well he was like
do you want to come to Mexico and I was
like honestly I'm still touring so it
would be easier if you could just come
to New York like it would just be so
much easier for me but did you guys so
he gets off the off the bug yes that's
the biggest test ride because you could
have all of the connection via FaceTime
but then the physical chemistry is the
only thing you're not sure about yeah
but when you when you saw him in person
you immediately think immediately I'm
like I know even touching oh yeah yeah
okay so I love them how long did he stay
off the first time uh just four days oh
that's it did you do spots uh no I
didn't I didn't do anything I wasn't
gonna be like bad guys
we did have a reception at the cellar
because we had a city hall wedding and I
was like I just told Liz who's the
manager I love her she's the best she's
the best and I was like can we just do a
reception at the seller thinking just a
place for us to meet up they had a
wedding cake they made for Johnny one of
the waiters made us a wedding cake and
it was so beautiful all my friends and
it was just a really beautiful day wow
yeah and did you so the second time now
did you go to Mexico I went to Mexico I
have a whole I I have a whole new bit
about it so I don't want to give it away
you don't have to give it away but
basically I was delayed seven and a half
hours because of a [__] volcano I was
stuck in the San Antonio Airport which
is the ugliest people I've ever seen
it was a nightmare but I made it I made
it to Mexico on Mexico yeah you haven't
been to El Paso but my point is
um so you and then so you went to Mexico
how long did you stay at that time uh I
stayed well that was two days and I came
back another a couple weeks and we
stayed I stayed for like uh 12 days or
something like that wow because then my
vacation started and then him and I went
to Italy together so I got to introduce
all my friends and family in Italy and
then we went back to Mexico back to
America and it just was like okay we're
in love did you meet his family when you
were yes yeah yeah I know his sister is
his now my niece uh his other sister his
mother his aunts they were so and you
know what's funny is like because I I
speak Spanish but I have like a really
thick Italian accent when I speak it
um they were just so much more chill
than Italians are like I was waiting for
like them to like kiss me and hug me but
they were like oh my God so nice to meet
you I'm like oh Rodrigo you're gonna be
attacked by my family we're gonna eat
you alive he's like no I'm ready for
ramore I'm like you're not you're not
ready for it you're not I'm gonna just
lose him in a sea of ants I just don't
wow I love that though I love just
physical like swarmed by physical
affection I know I read this article was
like don't force your child to hug an
adult if they'd like an uncle or Aunt if
they don't want to like give them their
space like this does not apply to
Italians yeah there's no personal space
my family knows so for us it's kind of